dog yeah we're just stalking chicks on
your Facebook thank you
yo P damn who is Maya Jane she's just
some chick yo she's like a Persian
princess Jasmine she looks like she
could get it is what she looks like some
chick is your buddy's pretty everybody's
pretty in profile pictures let's go to
them other pictures yeah the ones in
March March through break bra bikini pay
well I'm uncomfortable you pretend to be
friends with your exes I mean any time
your friends are dead ex is a [ __ ]
friend Sheila that is ridiculous
what's ridiculous what's this what's
that term that goofy ass actor term for
the meaning behind the words subtext
yeah that anytime you pretend to be
friends with your ex what you're really
saying is I want to smash sub Texas
that's your sub Texas jiggy you meet
your ex up she still looks good what do
you do I get a drunk talk about the
times we hit it and then we hit that's
what you do like up a [ __ ] today a
snips that's a hottie right there that
dude is a hotty toddy yes right me I'm
not gonna lie ready got a nice six-pack
that shirt look how low his hand is on
her hip
that's a couple that's a good
observation you had astute right now
yeah three months ago that guy's a
douchebag
oh I'm sorry you concerned as a friend
shut up yeah yeah I don't worry about
this dog you want your girl back I got
you don't worry send it a little
Facebook message we got this just go
pose for a box of Froot Loops without
[ __ ] it is you got to do all right
jiggies let's get on this let's do this
what's up no no no no no what's out
chicken all your pictures you still look
baingan G let's [ __ ] I don't know let me
know if you trying to get it question
mark
Aladdin emoticon what about like nothing
else might be face to face winky face
we've had
and sent goddamn beautiful that's
beautiful that's a magical tree that's
that Shakespearean this is Cupid does
she respond to the tropical last printed
shirt you're wearing
huh you think she respond to that
looking like a pack of gushers oh oh she
responded look at that nice okay that's
right
it's that jiggy method all right what'd
she say dude what'd she say she reported
you for abuse you're what you're banned
from Facebook gosh I don't know I see on
chicken and everything I use the
semicolon in between you look good yeah
I use any coordinate get it
don't call her she might hear loud a
shirt you're wearing okay